tyrannosaurus rex
king of the tyrant lizards
it's 6 meters tall 12 meters long
and it weighs upward of seven tons
you can hide from it you might even be
able to
outrun it but do you really want to do
this
every day
what would it be like to live with t-rex
would we keep them in zoos would we
eat them in restaurants
would we wear them on our backs
or would we live in constant fear
of being chomped clawed or trampled
this is what if and here's what would
happen
if t-rex were still alive
roughly 66 million years ago a massive
asteroid thought to be
about 15 kilometers wide
hit the earth with an impact equal to
several
million nuclear bombs detonating at once
this triggered the sudden mass
extinction of approximately
75 of all plant and animal species on
the planet
among them was the most powerful
terrestrial predator
to have ever lived the tyrannosaurus rex
as one of the most popular prehistoric
animals
being able to see a t-rex in the flesh
is
a pretty common fantasy but
what if we got what we wished for and
t-rex were still alive today
would humanity be able to survive
alongside
them were t-rex as
vicious and as ruthless as they appear
to be
in movies and tv or
would these massive dinosaurs be more
worried about
us than we'd be of them
[Music]
if t-rex were alive today chances are
they'd be an
endangered species their terrifying
reputation
would be no match for the habitat loss
pollution and
food shortages caused by humans because
of this
t-rex populations would be a lot smaller
and it's even possible that they would
have evolved to be a smaller size
we'd probably have to keep them in
sanctuaries
similar to a wildlife safari since
letting them roam freely would be
bad for both t-rex and humans
in the wild a t-rex would have to look
out for hunters or
poachers who'd want the thrill and the
bragging rights
of taking down a seven-ton beast
but even if you were smart enough to
keep your distance
a hungry t-rex looking for food might
find itself stumbling onto a farm or
breaking into a city zoo and
if you can't imagine a rampaging t-rex
storming around your city just imagine
an upright bus
with two legs and sharp teeth that have
a maximum fight force
of about 5 800 kilograms
but it's not like t-rex would always be
out hunting humans
scientific evidence suggests that t-rex
might have been more like scavengers
than
predators unlike most predators that
tend to have
super sharp vision a t-rex's eyes were
small and weak this dinosaur also
had unusually small arms compared to the
rest of their body
which wouldn't have been very effective
for fighting prey
however t-rex did have unusually large
olfactory lobes as part of their
brains which scientists think would have
been helpful for
smelling rotting carcasses from far away
but that same powerful sense of smell
might
also draw t-rex to country ranches or
urban meat factories which would almost
certainly end in disaster
a t-rex could eat up to 230 kilograms of
meat
in just one bite so your farm animals
wouldn't last very long
and if you wanted to defend them or
simply
prevent your house from being crushed
you
wouldn't be able to take on a t-rex
without a gun
and if you didn't have one you'd have to
run for your life
t-rex weren't super fast runners with
some scientists believing their top
speed was
around 16 kilometers an hour so if you
ran
and hid in a dense forest where it would
be hard for them to maneuver
you might be safe you could also try to
trip the t-rex that's chasing you since
they're top heavy dinosaurs that had a
hard time getting up if they fell
of course we wouldn't have to worry
about endangered livestock and
outsmarting t-rex if we kept them safely
confined
to wildlife preserves we could create
large habitats for them
and grow food to feed them so that their
appetites
wouldn't get them or us into trouble
the sanctuaries probably wouldn't look
like anything from jurassic park
since well we've seen how well that
worked
but maybe with enough space food and
under proper management humans could
coexist with t-rex
but the t-rex is just one type of
dinosaur
could we live with others too what do
you think the world would be like
if none of the dinosaurs ever went
extinct
well that's a story for another
what if
you